I've been told there's a man in the
audience tonight who refuses to give
thanks
he's parently right over there and he
will not he will not give thanks so
you're not feeling thankful this year
sir
nope you have nothing to be thankful at
all for it this year
nothing my life stinks okay well what
why why is that well first my job sucks
second my wife hates me third I feel
like crap literally literally all the
time fourth I lost my sense of taste in
a fireworks accident if no matter how
many showers I take I smell awful
sixth I'm afraid of a lot of shapes
triangles squares you name it circles
yeah see well sir I I got to admit that
that sucks what you just described
yeah you're damn right it sucks so
Thanksgiving no thanks well I don't know
what to say other than we appreciate you
being here tonight and well Steve can we
get this man a complimentary Conan mug
there you go
this mugs for me yes that months for you
I can have this mug that mug is all
yours thank you thank you thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
vii I always break the things that I
love Thanksgiving
they'll get over it
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography